[Music]
[Music]
Wow such a baller man
oh hey there I didn't see you there
just working out you know as you know
I'm turning into a Fitness channel but
now that you're here might as well give
you a tour of my apartment so this is my
personal gym as you can see it's pretty
dope you know this is where I get my
guns get my pump on but yeah let me show
you some other [ __ ] alright so here is
the common area oh actually you wait I
want to show you this can you pass me my
keys yeah this isn't it wait how's it
work
I should have rehearsed this before I
got nevermind alright so here's the
common area and if you remember this is
where I shot the scene with Arya where
he did so so you still working for
Microsoft you still working for
Microsoft I don't if you remember that
but yeah welcome to my crib these are
all the boats I'm pretty rich you know
that Adsense money you know gave me a
lot of money situated on a marina the
Italian architecture of this waterfront
community is striking
community amenities includes a marina
boardwalk a junior olympic-size swimming
pool and spa overlooking marina we live
in a three-bedroom two-bathroom
apartment with 1416 square feet costing
at around five thousand a month further
over you have something called like one
apartments those ones are like pretty
luxurious compared to this one this
one's probably at the lower end but you
know me I just it's really hard to it's
really hard to like pay the bills when
you're just the ic3 but it's okay you
know poor life alright alright here we
are this is my Villa and I live here
with two other roommates but they're not
here now so let's start the garage
[Music]
all right so here's a garage this is
this is probably the shittiest part of
my tour because it's pretty damn messy
but yeah these are my snowboarding gear
as you can see this is my snowboard my
bindings my boots and then I also have a
ten thousand dollar piano here that we
don't use it's actually an electric
piano but it's made to be like an
upright piano yeah
it's my brother's he's a rich I'm not
that's why he he has good stuff all
right
this is my roommates I think he's doing
some fashion thing I don't know all
right here's the washer washer dryer
washer dryer and then yeah and then all
the crap that we don't know where to put
we just put it here it's not bad all
right let's go check out the living room
oh damn it hidden water bottles damn it
alright okay oh [ __ ]
all right so welcome to the hallway
Nutter sets upstairs done Anna all right
right when you come in you can see all
my hand water bottles yeah I still
haven't finished them yet all right and
now we're in the living room usually
doesn't look like this but we're filming
today but yeah this is my bitmoji if you
guys recognize it it's usually all my
interviews it's pretty dope yeah so we
got this loveseat couch Oh feels good
and then we also have the one that is
more less comfortable but more solid
couch and then if you notice this is the
fireplace we could turn it on this is
where we shot start off with three by
the way so yeah pretty dope okay and
then if you go on to the kitchen area
you could see you can see a beautiful
clean table and then you also have the
chessboard I mean this is where we this
is where we shot start up three also
yeah you got some barstools but it's
supposed to be here I guess we then put
it here put this back all right so to
the kitchen it's extremely dirty why cuz
because I'm never in the kitchen so I
don't even use this I don't I don't know
where anything is but lots of protein
shake cups I don't use any more but I
might start using them
plates stuff like that let's look at the
fridge so what I got a block yeah so
none of this is mine but yeah it's okay
all right
let's go to my room now well actually
before that my bathroom
yeah don't film too much here it's
disgusting
so let's go up so obviously I spend most
of my time my room so this is probably
the best part of the tour see Oh already
it's so freaking dope I mean come on man
what else he put as a as a poster damn
oh it's so hot in here okay let me just
turn on the heater I usually have the
heater on I like it at 80 degrees k-pops
playing I'm gonna I'm gonna stop that I
don't want to get a copyright straight
it but yeah in the water let me take a
break mmm okay all right let's go
so here you can see is where I do most
of my videos because I have a light
setup so this is usually the main light
and then this is like kind of like a
fill light and then I have a tripod here
I put my camera on and then I start and
I say what's poppin you know and then if
I go live I usually have this thing this
is one of my best investment because
what you can do is you can just put it
here add a phone here and then I just go
live like this so easy yeah this is my
personal laptop I don't use it anymore
aside for watching porn but you know
nowadays I do everything here
I edit my videos i watch movies you know
i work and all that and then this is my
hard drive my hard drive to keep all the
files and then the this is an SD card
slot so basically this is like my
workplace
and then I also melatonin in case you
know I can't fall asleep so I would use
this this is the microphone that I use
it whenever I make those sit down videos
these are all my lenses
I got kit lens I got another kit lens I
actually have two of these cameras
because I love them so much they're two
a7s I'll put them all in the description
below if you want to buy them they're
pretty good and then also these anal
beads that keep my camera steady yeah
and then here I have all my Chargers
battery ports
you know I charge my phone and stuff
like that pretty dope so this is the bed
all the magic happens
and by magic I mean magic alone because
I can never get a girl here you know you
guys talked about this many times and
yes that is true but but I have a
back-up plan and let me show you I have
a Japanese mattress that can roll over
all right here there you go boom yeah if
ever I bring girls over I can't I can't
put her here because there's a 200 pound
limit but the floor doesn't have a 200
pound limit so there you go that's
another bed okay let's put this back
all right I'm gonna leave it here for
now oh [ __ ] god this room is small
all right here what else oh okay so here
you can see got my accessory I usually
have a plate and a fork here because I
don't want to be liable for anything in
the kitchen because I want to use 1/4
and one plate so they can't blame me for
anything I got my I got my awesome
painting it's pretty dope I got Lube
it's mostly for myself I got ooh look at
this this is a dope ass comic book
haven't read it yet kind of dyslexic I'd
only read but yeah let's see oh iPhone
all right that's not an iPhone it's a
pixel but yeah and then in here I have
utter crap I just store everything oh
all the wires because you know camera
gears and all that I have way too many
wires converters stuff like this boom
what else oh I got a lot of banana
holders yeah I got a lot of banana
holders I never use them yet because I
usually just eat the banana before I
even before I even like before I even
carry it so I don't need that okay
out oh yeah okay I think that's about it
you know I got art and then this is this
is my clean pile there's my dirty pile
that's usually what it is oh I guess
I'll show you my toys look look God why
is it so far
[Music]
all right so here's my Corgi you know
very popular Corgi but one other toy you
don't know that I have because you know
I expose it last is called beemo it's
basically like a robot octopus yeah it's
pretty cute he used to be my favorite
until I got the Corgi but hello okay all
right let's go back down
[Music]
doo-doo-doo all right so that's that's
basically it so thank you for touring
with me and I hope I hope you liked it
in case you want to know this costs
about $5,000 a month I pay a thousand
five hundred because I got the smallest
room and yeah peace out oh yeah don't
forget to Like and subscribe you know
and do that thing peace
[Music]